our pilot project program was originally
designed to allow scientists to study
areas of women's health that had never
before been undertaken so our pilot
project program offers the opportunity
for investigators to compete for dollars
so that if they are awarded a grant from
us they can undertake a new study on a
particular area of women's health that's
important to them and important to the
health of women it can be on an area of
cancer research it can be on depression
osteoporosis autoimmune illness
cardiovascular disease smoking cessation
any number of topics that are really
critical to women's health
the ability to get federal grants is
completely based on your ability to show
that what you're doing is going to work
and therefore sources of pilot funding
are extremely useful in starting a new
direction or in taking on studies that
might otherwise be too expensive to do
with existing funding and I think
Women's Health Research at Yale has been
very good at leveraging their their
funding and they're particularly their
pilot grants in order to get people who
weren't already working on sex and
gender issues to start incorporating
that as an important part of the
research
one of the difficulties I found in my
work is that when you want to try a new
method or as a junior faculty member one
you want to learn a new method and then
write a grant to fund some ideas you
know some pilot work it's very difficult
to get to get that research funded in a
large part because as a junior faculty
member you don't have a track record of
publishing with new research methods or
in this area of study so Women's Health
Research provides pilot money and seed
money and also the mentorship for you to
explore new areas and then obtain pilot
data which will allow you to find larger
projects further on in your career
women's health research at Yale funded a
pilot project in my laboratory and it
actually was a collaboration with dr.
Alessandro santan who's in the
department of obstetrics and gynecology
Alessandro is an expert in ovarian
cancer and has long been trying to find
new ways to treat ovarian cancer
particularly that subset of ovarian
cancer that is resistant to most drugs
and and this is a common form of ovarian
cancer unfortunately and in my
laboratory we develop methods for
delivering drugs to to tumors more
effectively and this involves embedding
the drug molecules into very tiny
particles called nanoparticles and and
then decorating these nanoparticles so
that they recognize tumors and avoid all
other cells in the body and so the
Women's Health Research at Yale pilot
program allowed us to do the first
experiments in combining our two
interests to find new treatments for
ovarian cancer
we're not interested in people leaving
their errors of study and identifying
themselves solely as women's health
investigators rather we much prefer that
people stay right where they are
in the discipline in which they work and
then begin their to embrace women's
health to embrace gender differences in
what they're already studying and in
that way in the long term we'll
mainstream the study of women's health
particularly now federal dollars are
scarce and as a consequence of that our
program is reaching out for funds to
help our investigators not only get the
pilot funds they need but also looking
for bridge funds until they can get
larger funds in order to study
definitive answers to the questions that
we have about women's health